[Music]
hey everyone we're here at the Google
cloud next Developer zone this is full
of cool little showcases hands-on labs
tutorials and of course the dead zone
stage where people are able to come here
and learn all about the cool things but
really get their hands on them and play
around with them speaking of which
we're at the BQ ML station with Felipe
Hoffa who loves data and bigquery so
Felipe tell me a little bit more about
what we're looking at here hi mark so
what we have here is a stack overflow
predictor how long will it take for
people to answer your question so what
does that mean specifically so I can go
in the stack overflow I can ask a
question but someone's not gonna respond
immediately yeah so I don't know if you
ever asked a question on Stack Overflow
it takes some time and you never know
how long will it take well with this
tool we can kind of predict how long
will it take looking at all the past
data that we have from Stack Overflow
now how do you do that because bigquery
you can do a bunch of data analysis but
you can't build a machine learning model
in bigquery right well you can now
so I love the query I love that one
Linux thanks to the public data program
we have a copy of Stack Overflow
the damn table they publish every
quarter so we load the data in bigquery
and then you can start running your own
sequel queries over it anyone can come
and run any query they want they have a
free terabyte every month so the first
step with that analytics is just to look
at all your questions look at all your
answers and get an average of how long
did it take for people to answer
questions on Stack Overflow so people
can come here to the next showcase floor
play around with this interface here
change and see if they ask a question
and then based on the machine learning
model don't see about how long they'd
have to wait for someone to go and
answer it exactly so how did we go from
the analytics of just average group by
to a prediction and there's a lot of
spaces in between right for example to
get an answer for the Google bigquery
tag 8:00 a.m. for a medium question that
ends with a that's an end with a
question mark that starts with a Y for
someone that creates an account in 2017
we're predicting that it will take 53
minutes
maybe they will not get an answer but
with an 85 percent probability they will
get one and they there is a chance of
being downloaded of about a 7% for this
statistics now how do we build this we
used we created a linear regression
using all of these features and the data
that we have available so with all this
different information you can know when
you ask a question
approximately hopefully pretty
relatively when it's gonna be answered
but you could also maybe even predict
when's the best time to ask a question
exactly if you want to go the opposite
way so let's say it takes 53 minutes or
not you say Sunday
it takes more like an hour to get an
answer but there's a higher chance of
getting an answer so lots of cool
information to play around with here but
people can also come here and actually
learn bql hands-on right exactly so
there are two alternatives for people
that are not here to see how I made this
they can go to my blog plus a medium
just search for Felipe Hoffa
when will Stack Overflow reply and if
you are here and next we have Cod laughs
ready for you to run that you can also
find online but there's some many ways
to learn and get your hands into these
tools perfect so lots of cool stuff for
me qml come down to the floor get
started or check out the resources
online
[Music]